i saw this drew and i knew you would
love it it was on apartment therapy
i knew i had to tell you about it you do
you ever play with legos
as a kid uh not really but as a parent
i certainly know them because when i
step on them i want to
scream louder than i've ever screamed
before okay well um i can't help you
with that but this makes legos even more
fun
they have just released a brand new
concept called lego flowers
it's their botanical collection so if
you can't grow it
now you can build it and we have some
here this
really speaks to me well i thought it'd
be kind of total cheese fest when i
first heard about it on my eye roll
but look how cute they are no gorgeous
as like a little centerpiece
cute and i had the same idea at the same
time let me fluff it that's why we're
that's why we're here together i love it
i
also lego just announced that it's um
because of this kid we actually had a
story when we first launched about their
cognizant um use of plastic and how
they're going to change their packaging
in order to be more green
oh really so thank you lego thank you
keeping it green all the way around
green gardens okay i just saw this post
on
healthline asking a vital question for
our times
can crying help you lose weight
well the answer is not really only at a
rate of 1.3
calories per minute do you burn when
you cry because by the way if it did i'd
be thin as a rail
it would be if it did i was like okay
tonight it's steel magnolias
the notebook terms of endearment i know
god i love those movies maybe throw in a
postcards from the edge
all day how about a bridges of madison
county eddie meryl streep it's
complicated
okay yeah i'll do that something's got
to give i'll do that one too i love
something's got to get i need nancy
meyer's movie yes
and are you a really legit a big crier i
mean have you seen the show well that's
true
i do you cry as much at home as you do
here
probably you know
here's the difference with my crying and
like you know just
a a mess of a human being i
cry because i'm passionate about things
or i cry in reaction to just how much
i'm marveling at my kids
i'm not like a constant breaker downer
and
i recently had some things that happened
and
it was tough and it was really hard to
digest
and at the end of the day i was re
relieved
that i wasn't like emotional baggage and
i didn't make my
problems everybody else's problems and i
was able to brush it off and like pick
myself up and move on
so the older i get definitely the better
i get but i'm an emotional girl for sure
you know when i was growing up i always
thought i thought crying was a weakness
because i needed to show strength
because people pick on me and then
when you go through stuff as you get
older you realize that being able to cry
is such a strong thing to do because
it's allowing yourself to be vulnerable
for a second and
knowing that you'll come out the other
side of those tears you know yeah that's
that's powerful
you